whoa what the hell just wait whoa whoa
whoa what the hey get out of my house oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay we're fine
all right so hi welcome to three scary
games spooky intro well oh very spooky
very spooky various but good things
happening spooky things all over the
this is a demo for a game that seems
like it might just be something spooky
so new game let's just go into it this
one's called well I'm in house usually
how these things go okay can't go in
there
very slow caught a member of the sect
there was a mass murder of people the
suspect was arrested perhaps this is the
work of some cult we are looking for the
leaders headquarters along with other
participants so Who am I am i involved
in this hunt am I responsible for
something here the key that's a cute
baby
that's cute Rumble all this is very cute
very cute stuff going on here love it
I'm not gonna look where that baby was
left click interact right click
alternative interact pick up an item
open the door with a key middle mouse
focus look v lighter okay good you got
it thanks for the note can I sit I pop a
squat I'm guessing because I don't
actually have a tape focus look lighter
all right got it can I go through here
[Music]
baby hey baby
oh that's not a baby that's not a baby
that's not a baby I have none of those
babies get some pills
slam them down can't read this okay well
the baby's not gonna be an artist I can
see that for sure
alright good great great okay lock it's
good you know what I'm happy about that
I don't have to go looking through stuff
like a lot of these games seem to want
me to do cool wait what but it's just
the two rooms am I supposed to be able
to open this other door well see how
this is a conundrum here there's only
two rooms so how would I be able to do
anything
oh hello hang on one second can't see it
too dark bill and Matilda's wedding
great good for Bill and Matilda March
1986 bill Matilda Kate Grace and nil C
1986 this doesn't seem like 1986
considering I was born in 89 this seems
like early 1900s at best okay well this
is a supplement this isn't even a this
is this is calcium calcium in [ __ ] acam
bogel uh coffee bean extract that's not
even a medication am I missing something
here missing something I mean true to
its word I do appear to be locked up all
right cool Hey okay I didn't expect
there to be something like that
okay just steady Stumpy's for no reason
just step you Stumpy's for no wait a
minute
Oh baby who put their toys away
Oh baby what a good baby what a good
baby
Oh still not an artist though still
really lacking in the art department
glue funding at the art school is
lurking all right um yeah this is great
yeah mm-hmm good job kiddo you're gonna
go far wait a minute wait a minute what
are you doing to me what are you doing
to me game
every baby alright five people died in
an accident five people died two were
injured in a collision between a
motorcycle and a pickup truck 1986 yeah
you bet yeah you bet baby that's a lot
of pills baby Oh
who's been a bad baby I've been a bad
baby with a lot of pills I don't think a
baby needs to have many pills saying
that out loud I don't think a baby needs
that many pills
all right good thing I'm locked in here
well ball can ball dude three points how
do I like training with it oh oh no oh
no I broke it guys ah [ __ ] okay I can't
I can't drop it I can't turn my lighter
net oh never mind I put the ball in the
oh oh I see I see what I'm supposed to
do I need to die see I need to pick up
the toys I don't I can't seem dude oh
there we go okay let's yeah there we go
okay right click right click it's right
click ok I got it I got it I got it
picking up the toys even on the baby
through the turn from small my fault
after the baby go baby go big baby
cool great good you will you welcome
baby
welcome I thought that was unlocked
hello hey hey hey why you off-kilter Hey
Oh you drinking wine there buddy you
drinking wine there buckaroo no okay
does that chamber pot and a pot for
pissing in a lot of bottles a lot of
pills that's a big baby oh that's a big
baby that's a big baby all right
Oh baby's gone okay baby up baby's gone
all right cool good Oh what whoa baby go
went to art school
what did wait a minute baby baby got
good oh well mind if I join you okay
Grampy you know you're not supposed to
be here you're supposed to be never mind
I can't pick you up anymore all right
Grampy pampy don't want to be up on the
thing that's fine I am NOT one to tell
grandpa vampy what to do
Oh
grabby baby's in timeout you just don't
need to look at that thanks buddy he's
still there grandpa oh yeah okay cool
[Applause]
that is incredibly dark oh that is
incredibly dark
oh that net can I get this ax no I can't
okay good great stuff great stuff that's
a great actor but it's so dark in here
doors opened wow it's dark so pervasive
so incredibly dork
ah good there's more hosts
wonderful locked good hello me who's
there who's there Oh No thank you go get
the baby Oh crappy babes
I'll grab me baby are you doing it here
[Music]
oh-oh-oh-oh
no where would they be walking dude
there's only so many X's out of that
room yeah I saw one big prank I get it I
get it funny jokes
we got funnier we have fun just joking
around having a good laugh enjoying
ourselves I didn't expect that to open
oh no no those baby handprints will
happen to baby
baby's gone baby's gone baby's gone Oh
baby gone
Oh baby's gone whoa the art oh it's
changed okay symbol
all right simple simple simple simple
great oh great okay good Greg glad glad
I'm glad I'm glad okay I'm glad hello oh
it's dork
is dork oh oh I can't go here anymore
oh-ho-ho-ho no no no you are not the one
who blows I am the one who blows I'll
blow you so hard all your candles will
be blown B to blow you ways had a baby
I'm gonna guess the wailing of the dance
saint moon I didn't even see you what
are you doing here Satan how you been
buddy Oh
you need someone to light these candles
for you meal with will if little F is
that your rap name oh good
oh great Oh Rick wall
oh okay so I gotta pick up the toys
again oh okay alright didn't know these
were safe baby's first Satan summoning
right right of course all right okay
cool yeah ha ha ha ha ha ha thank you uh
oh
well this grandpa baby still has his
chair oh [ __ ]
movies on oh [ __ ] move is it ok waiting
for the big scare at the end oh well
that's a problem yes
that's what some people might call
problem ooh
hmm look you got it you got it I'm
looking let's put her in I'm looking
baby oh I'm looking all right I'm
looking right at it
play there we go
I'm looking baby okay here I'm looking
I'm looking baby don't know what I'm
looking for but I'm looking Oh
my oh okay this is me okay well there's
some rope the funny feeling I know
what's gonna happen with that good
picture okay time period still a little
a little funky on this time period
little funky little funky just a little
bit okay okay do I have a lighter no I
do not I can't even go in there you know
what I didn't want to go in there anyway
okay I can't go anywhere oh oh hey oh I
guessed correctly oh oh okay oh no yeah
I already knew oh that's that's it now
that was the demo I see the reflection
of the text in the mirror all right not
a hundred percent sure what the moral of
the story is however that was very good
I like that a lot I think there was a
lot of potential there I think that was
great I think that was really really
good stuff really hot spicy horror just
good good stuff that being said I don't
know what the moral of the story was but
sometimes I guess you don't need to know
all right moving on all right so this
one is called tasty ramen it is a horror
game about ramen I'm just lost as you oh
hey welcome to this special gameplay
demo version of tasty ramen just a quick
explanation before we can start you can
run while holding the shift key grab
items by pressing e you can place them
again by pressing E again pressing the
left mouse button makes you throw them
remember items say hit the ground can
make attracting noises one last thing if
you get tired of the game escape lets
you leave right away that's it let's go
[Music]
oh oh wait what i'v wait wait what a
what wait wait wait I'm sorry oh [ __ ] oh
god oh god oh my god oh okay I get it
oh oh I see oh I see oh okay I see I see
I see what's going on what oh I'm doomed
I'm doomed I'm doomed I'm done okay I
get it
oh boy okay what happens how do you get
away once the spots here is it just doom
it's just doom isn't it oh my guess doom
oh no it's not doomed hey what happens
if I just gather up the keys [ __ ] one
two three four five six one two three
four five I have five over here I need
one more ready to go where's the last
one not seeing it oh my god I'm not
seeing it oh there it is this should be
like the last one right
where'd you go oh [ __ ] oh okay I got
this oh my god come on come on come on
come on oh my god come on hey hi haha
you did it very impressive I hope you
enjoyed this gameplay
oh that's it oh there's no second level
oh that's it my Marcus horn music's
taiko drums Oh
conga bunga's Oh soldier this evil 3000
sound effect pack
Marcus horn Elena from Winkler Ike
okay okay okay thanks man thank you
thank you my dude oh all right well I
was hoping it was gonna be more and more
like a surreal horror but apparently
that's that's what we get it's not bad I
want to say that straight up it's not
bad not bad at all not bad not bad okay
so this one is called the Black Rose I
like this styling of this one oh my
heart is racing there was something
special about her everything about her
felt so familiar it's shrouded in a veil
of mystery have we met I swear you look
familiar
it might have been a mixture of sweet
perfume and tobacco the first caught my
attention the way she spoke to me felt
so natural like we had talked a thousand
times before
every gesture and every expression made
my heart skip a beat we talked for what
felt like hours the last thing she asked
was if we should meet again and before I
knew it she was gone she had left me a
note with a place of time I just
couldn't resist like smelling the nectar
of forbidden fruit I have to see her
again it feels like I'm meant to be here
I have a funny feeling that you're not
meant to be here this is a trap don't do
it no don't go in there all right fine
whatever I'm go oh [ __ ] Oh what the
hell oh I thought it was gonna be like
that the whole time ah but that's cool
okay come find me regret nothing trust
your instincts 69 oh hell yeah oh don't
leave me like this
heartbreaker kills cider apple trust
apple cider worth it
honey died a hole I love it there's a
lot of details in here hey buddy buddy
naughty naughty naughty white a man
who's been writing you notes I've been
writing you notes he oh okay well
darling dearest we'll come find me oh
babe
whoa beer babe babe babe babe what is in
there eggs aren't sure whatever baby
baby hey baby hey baby ooh baby baby
baby baby wearing that whoa
diamond drop between the sheets
Oh mine Oh baby it's cold outside
oh but baby it's warm inside oh god baby
can you guys tell I don't flirt on the
regular
but I'm amazing at it stop looking at me
darling ahaha snookums
honey Lumpkins baby oh wait a minute
[Music]
way to me
why
baby baby afraid of change leave it here
womanizer cocktail beer liar okay
naughty naughty naughty someone's been
naughty yeah me yeah I've been naughty
yeah that's me baby baby baby oh what
the hell
baby
hey baby hey baby baby baby baby baby
baby baby baby baby oh hey baby hey baby
hey baby baby baby baby alright
hey how you doing module how you doing
are you doing are you doing okay good
good to hear
Oh working late again oh you know you
know how it is you know how it be you
know how I do babe
aha Yellow Rose interesting I love me a
good looping mechanic I sincerely do
trust me you know it baby
babe oh no oh no no no I don't like the
implication no you're closer no I don't
like the implication
oh that's terrifying to be who you're
closer I don't like the implication is
horrifying maybe
baby baby baby baby baby oh the chignon
I don't know this hunan those who know
am i a married man am i a married man
who should not be here oh I'm a married
man who should not be here aren't I
you I don't like you ah god damn it I'm
a goof hi oh my god oh my god how long
has that been up there oh hey I hate it
I hate it I really hate it I hate it I
hate it
Oh hate it oh oh oh
what have you done I don't know what
have you done what have you done what
have you done you played with my heart
that's the war thing and anybody could
have done you played with my hearts my
tender heart how close is this thing
gonna be please don't be very close it's
bad thing I've always hated that don't
go where you go Rock Hill
[Music]
no no no no no I don't like this unlike
anything that's going on
[Applause]
that's alright fine
I was probably fine that's probably
completely fine little late for regrets
do you think I regret anything what you
talked about I live my life without
regrets baby baby
does she know I don't know stay with me
the concept of just getting closer and
look at that boom
no thank you Wow holy [ __ ] oh wait no
you're not actually supposed to be a
thing oh no no no no what do i do what
do i do what do i do what do i do what
do i do what do I do about you what do I
do about you oh my god oh oh here I have
was she the only one I don't know I
don't know what you're talking about
I've never been on one date let alone
multiple okay raw clear all clear baby
oh no we're not no we're not nam fed
didn't know I could eat that oh there
she is oh she's back okay okay oh yeah
okay I get what I get I was I was
supposed to not die hi that's the idea
maybe I don't know
oh no I'm wait what uh well hang on a
second here oh that's the opposite of
good oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god there we go oh baby
oh my vision got real wide angle well
that's that's weird um nineteen black
rose come find me come find me that rose
is black definitely is I could just eat
you up well me too - you go stubble for
you lady take a seat okay pop squat
isn't this what you wanted I don't know
what have you done
[Music]
that was one of the scariest experiences
I've had in a long time that was really
well made it told the story really well
throughout the whole game I understood
it pretty clear from the get-go that was
great
truly and honestly that was a great
horror experience I'm very happy with
that one
that was wonderful alright so that is
three scary games if you want to see
more of these videos subscribe and ring
that bell to be notified of when I do
more scary games and if you've got scary
games that you want me to play write
them down in the comments below or leave
a like just to say you enjoyed this
video thank you play so much you want to
play these they're all linked in the
description and as always I will see you
in the next video moral this story don't
cheat
or you'll die don't you
[Music]